Je veux que tu fasses cet endroit pour l'honneur
tu as le vrai cadeau
mais tu as une école à payer Je ne suis pas
éligible à une aide financière Je possède 60
mille frais de scolarité dus la semaine prochaine et c'est
si je ne mange pas, bienvenue dans le vrai  La première mondiale au niveau
national est votre projet de jouer
pour l'argent de vos frais de scolarité doit être vraiment
agréable de faire payer vos études
Rica tu es sur le point
de t'envoler vers un pays où tu n'es jamais
allé avec une langue que tu ne parles pas
donne une idée à quel point c'est fou mon
nom Ivan
Richie Furst c'est la maison pourquoi la
maison la maison gagne toujours c'est pourquoi
nous n'avons pas besoin de tromper les gens mais les
calculs sont justes est-ce que je manque quelque chose aucun
risque de programme a décidé d'écrire une porte dérobée
dans le code
un vrai business
garanti à sept chiffres  les 18 premiers
mois sont ravis de te voir dépenser que
dis-tu que penses-tu que tu
m'appelles agent rase le FBI dans le secteur des
enlèvements soudoie maintenant un
racket officiel tu n'as aucune idée de
ce dans quoi tu t'es embarqué pourquoi
le FBI est partout  moi, demande-toi juste
est-ce que tu fais quelque chose de mal sommes-nous
bonjour j'ai quelque chose que j'ai besoin que tu fasses
mon ami ouais ton patron j'envoie un
bloc de message tu m'as mis en place c'est ton
travail tu veux un travail plus sûr va travailler pour le
poste  le bureau veut avoir bonne conscience, allez
créer une association caritative, mais si vous voulez votre propre
île et que votre patron dit allez-y
et prenez une raclée, allez-y,
revenez au travail et dites que vous avez besoin de moi
pour le refaire, vous allez  obtenez-nous les
preuves sur le bloc je dois sortir de
ça ce sont des crocodiles ouais
mon pote veut me prendre un morceau